hey was geht ab herzlich willkommen beim
ein video
ich muss mich heftig beeilen aber ich
hab was krasses vor was heißt was
krasses also ist schon krass und zwar
ich wollte ja letztens von herab so
geprägt so war ganz witzig aber das
beste ist ja immer wenn man den
zurückbringt deswegen es passt gerade
alles perfekt und zwar ich hatte
letztens irgendwann mal für meinen
bruder so kreide spray geholt und zwar
wollte ich den verarschen allerdings hat
das irgendwie überhaupt nicht geklappt
deswegen habe ich mir das gedacht hey du
hast display noch macht bringen was mit
und zwar kommt vielleicht herz also ich
kann nicht mal kurz erklären was kreide
spray ist man kann das halt überall
drauf spray und das feld wieder ab wenn
man drüber geht so dass es halt nicht
schädlich ist aber es sieht halt aus so
wie graffiti im ersten augenblick sah
ich mal wollte ich kriege das gleich
besuch von herr asche kommt jetzt sofort
bekommt von seinen verwandten aus keine
ahnung wurde immer ist und er hat mich
gefragt ob ich ladekabel hat weil er
kein akku märz mit fünf prozent so kennt
das problem und ich bin ja natürlich
nett deswegen gebe ich ihnen natürlich
mein ladekabel
dort will er dann sein handy anschließen
und keine ahnung ich lass mir dann
irgendwas einfallen meint denn auch
irgendwas 3 ist es dass wir nach unten
geht oder weg geht kein plan so es
klingelt an der türe oder was weiß ich
keine ahnung ich finde schon irgendwas
ja genau dann nehme ich einfach sein
handy und spät das komplett ein mit
diesem kreide spray tan ist ein ganzes
handy weiß und er denkt natürlich dass
es jetzt kaputt bin gespannt wie er
reagiert ich kann die kamera auch noch
an machen die steht ihr ehemann das weiß
er auch
und ja dann würde ich sagen viel spaß
für ein bisschen der bericht aber das
wird schon
und jetzt also leute ich drehe das jetzt
hier um das sieht man nicht dass hier
läuft die steht hier immer so eigentlich
hier meistens steht die arbeit wenn es
merkt ja alles okay ich zu dieser kamera
dass so ein kleines ding durch einfach
hierhin solist
für beide töten
das können sich bis zum 1
kommt
lasst einfach kurz hier nicht dass hier
erfolgt war ich ganz cool water gibt
seht ihr mich so wie es seine nie okay
leute sein handy liegt so wie vorher
nach hause
ich hab auch liest du das nicht
was sind behindert einer richtigen farbe
lieber gesicht aus malermeister krieg
wollen am anfang einer mine war da muss
mich ganz kurz darauf floh warte such
mal kannst du mal diese weist diese
diese wollte diese größe sd karte
sie liegt immer bei meiner tochter
ermitteln willst du mich finden
ich kann nicht morgen mehr was erkennen
aber ich hab's man das hat ist nichts
schlimmes dinger ich habe ein neues
handy ich hatte hier noch dieses das
kannst du auch machen ich denke wir auch
noch die ganze zeit das weiß warum es im
fahrbericht deswegen kummer ich hatte
von meinem freund mein bruder noch
verarschen wurstsalat ist immer mein
bett ist auch mein bett ist jetzt auch
es geht nicht wählt man mal geht das weg
ja leute wollen die leute vor allem um
ein display hat einen totalschaden und
echte das einfach mal locker übertrifft
schon kaputt es habe schon draußen
ziehen die reinbringen und gucken sie
diese leute in ihrem prinzgemahl leute
er sagte mir das geht ab heute konnte
ich das mal bitten
aber ganz ehrlich hättest du keinen wert
jetzt nicht hingefallen das wäre perfekt
abhören das jetzt alles perfekt zwischen
diesen sitzen aber das ist eigentlich
geil aus also ich hätte gern ein handy
ja keines platz drin
er hält bei wittlich bis jetzt gut nur
aber eigentlich jetzt schon cool und
sehen gut aus also leute in bern rissen
das war ich total weg jetzt das war es
auf jeden fall mit dem video wenn es
euch gefallen hat wird uns sehr freuen
wenn den daumen nach oben da las schaut
auch bei ihm vorbei link ist ganz oben
in der video beschreibung verlinkt leute
das betrachtet laufen mir dass wir am
samstag kaum noch ein video von uns
beiden da kündigen wir so ein kleines
zuschauer was als kleines ankündigen wie
ein zuschauer treffen in bielefeld an
deswegen check am samstag ab aber nicht
vergessen server als ein gewöhnliches
arbeiter mit einer metz video könnt ihr
auch gerne vorbeischauen school geworden
und peace glauben ist es ganz kleines
bisschen gelungen ich dachte erst es
mehr aus aber zweck